le danube célèbre fleuve européen devenu
une sortie de secours du conflit
ukrainien chaque jour ils sont des
centaines à braver le froid et traverser
le cours d'eau comme aux autres points
de passage ce sont surtout des femmes et
des enfants qui descendent du bateau
natalia s'inquiète pour ses grands
parents restés dans la région de dessin
à bord du traversier elle a retrouvé par
hasard son ami joulia marquée par les
sons des bombes et des sirènes
quand on entend un bruit on se demande
ce qui va se produire dit elle cette
ukrainienne aimerait bien trouver refuge
auprès de proches au canada mais elle
n'a pas encore décidé si elle s'y rendra
pour de nombreux réfugiés la roumanie
n'est qu'une escale dans un long voyage
et n'a ils ont prévu tous les plans ils
ont des amis qui allaient chercher ils
ont de la famille tiennent les chercher
et y en a juste y
ils ont fui d'entrée leurs bagages et
ils vont étape par étape ça fera trois
ya vraiment tous les profils mais tous
savent ce qu'ils laissent derrière eux
plusieurs de ces réfugiés vient de la
région d'odessa la ville portuaire a été
relativement épargnée jusqu'à présent
mais les autorités sont en alerte et
crainte des bombardements
la taxe sur un hôpital pour enfants de
mario paul à l'est du pays et tu
resteras pelle que cette menace est bel
et bien réel tout comme les combats
amicaux live à 130km d'odessa c'est dans
cette région que se trouvait la femme de
bill un torontois qui s'est rendu
jusqu'à la frontière roumaine
ma femme était effrayée sans eau
nourriture ou électricité dit cet homme
qui est ici depuis six jours dans la
tente il a décidé d'aider les réfugiés
sa femme a finalement réussi à atteindre
la frontière après des heures d'attentes
fausse alerte elle n'est pas sûre ce
traversier il faudra encore patienter
une fois réunies le couple restera
quelques temps en roumanie pour
participer aux efforts de bénévolat
avant de finalement s'envoler pour la
destination finale le canada il sera
fait le bouvier auclair radio canada ice
edge en roumanie